Les couleurs qu'elle adorait porter étaient sans doute la seule chose
qui exprimait son identité véritable,
la seule chose sur laquelle elle avait du pouvoir,
car comme la plupart des femmes de sa génération en Inde,
elle n'avait jamais eu le droit d'exister
au-delà de ce qui était dicté par les coutumes ou la tradition.
On l'a mariée à l'âge de 17 ans,
et après 65 ans de mariage, mon grand-père est mort soudainement.
Sa perte était insupportable.
Mais ce jour-là, elle allait perdre quelque chose d'autre aussi,
la seule joie qu'elle avait :
porter des couleurs.
En Inde, comme c'est la coutume,
quand une femme hindoue devient veuve,
elle n'a le droit de porter que du blanc
à compter de la mort de son mari.
Personne ne l'a obligée à porter du blanc.
Pourtant, toutes les femmes qu'elle a connues qui avaient survécu à leur mari,
y compris sa mère,
l'avaient fait.
Cette oppression était tellement internalisée
et profondément enracinée,
qu'elle a rejeté le choix.
Elle est décédée cette année
et jusqu'au jour de sa mort,
elle n'a porté que du blanc.
J'ai une vieille photo avec elle d'une époque heureuse.
On ne voit pas très bien ce qu'elle porte
car la photo est en noir et blanc.
Pourtant, son sourire nous dit
qu'elle porte de la couleur.
C'est ce que nous apporte la mode.
Elle a le pouvoir de nous remplir de joie,
la joie de la liberté de pouvoir choisir ce à quoi on veut ressembler,
comment on veut vivre --
une liberté qui vaut qu'on se batte.
Or, se battre pour la liberté, protester, prend beaucoup de formes.
En Inde, des milliers de veuves comme ma grande-mère
vivent dans la ville Vrindavan.
C'est un océan de blanc depuis des siècles.
Pourtant, en 2013, il n'y a pas si longtemps,
les veuves de Vrindavan ont commencé à fêter Holi,
la fête de la couleur en Inde,
qui leur était interdite.
Pendant un jour en mars,
ces femmes prennent la poudre colorée traditionnelle de la fête
et se colorent mutuellement.
Chaque poignée de poudre jetée en l'air
répand progressivement de la couleur sur leurs saris blancs
jusqu'à les recouvrir complètement
de toutes les nuances de l'arc-en-ciel qui leur sont interdites.
Les couleurs partent au lavage le lendemain,
toutefois, cet instant précis
représente une rupture magnifique.
Ce désordre,
tout signe de dissonance,
peut être le premier jet de pierres à l'encontre de l'oppression.
Et la mode
peut créer une rupture visuelle
sur nous, littéralement.
Il y a toujours eu des attitudes de défi
chez les grands révolutionnaires de la mode :
ses couturiers.
Jean-Paul Gaultier nous a enseigné que les femmes peuvent être des rois.
Thom Browne
nous a dit que les hommes peuvent porter des talons.
Et Alexander McQueen, pendant son défilé du printemps 1999,
a mis deux bras géants articulés au centre de son podium.
Et, quand le mannequin Shalom Harlow a virevolté entre les deux robots,
ces deux bras géants --
furtivement d'abord et de plus en plus frénétiquement,
se sont mis à la vaporiser de couleurs.
McQueen, par conséquent,
avant qu'il ne se suicide,
nous a montré que notre corps est une toile,
une toile sur laquelle on peut peindre ce que l'on veut.
Une personne qui a adoré ce monde de la mode
était Karar Nushi.
C'était un étudiant et un acteur irakien.
Il adorait ses vêtements diaprés et éclectiques.
Cependant, il a commencé à recevoir des menaces de mort pour son apparence.
Mais ça l'a laissé indifférent.
Katar est resté fabuleux,
jusqu'en juillet 2017,
quand on l'a découvert mort dans une rue animée de Bagdad.
Il avait été kidnappé.
Il avait été torturé.
Des témoins oculaires ont dit qu'il avait de multiples blessures.
De coups de couteaux.
A Peshawar, à trois mille kilomètres de là,
Alisha, une activiste pakistanaise transgenre, a été emmenée à l'hôpital
après avoir été touchée par balles en mai 2016.
Mais elle était habillée comme une femme
et on lui a refusé l’accès à la salle des femmes et l'accès à la salle des hommes.
Ce qu'on choisit de porter peut être une question de vie ou de mort, littéralement.
Et même dans la mort, on n'a toujours pas toujours le choix.
Alisha est morte ce jour-là
et fut enterrée en tant qu'homme.
Mais dans quel monde vit-on ?
Eh bien, un monde où il est normal d'avoir peur,
d'avoir peur de cette surveillance,
de cette violence contre nos corps et ce qu'on porte.
Pourtant, il y a une peur plus grande encore, qui est celle d'abandonner,
de s'uniformiser,
et de disparaître l'un après l'autre.
Plus cette fausse conformité nous paraîtra normale,
et moins choquante cette oppression nous paraîtra.
Pour les enfants qu'on élève,
l'injustice d’aujourd’hui pourrait devenir l'ordinaire de demain.
Ils vont s'habituer à ça.
Eux aussi pourraient se mettre à considérer toute différence comme sale,
quelque chose à détester,
quelque chose à éliminer,
comme des lumières qu'on éteint,
une par une,
jusqu’à ce que l’obscurité devienne un mode de vie.
Pourtant, si moi aujourd'hui,
et vous demain,
et un jour, un plus grand nombre de nous,
si nous acceptons pleinement le droit de ressembler à nous-mêmes,
dans ce monde blanchi brutalement à la chaux,
on sera comme des échardes de couleurs,
comme les veuves de Vrindavan.
Comment alors, parmi une telle assemblée,
pourra-t-on cibler dans la ligne de mire,
Karar,
Malala,
et Alisha ?
Peuvent-ils nous tuer tous ?
L'heure est venue de se dresser,
de se démarquer.
Là où uniformité signifie sécurité,
avec quelque chose d'aussi simple que ce que l'on porte,
on peut attirer tous les regards sur nous,
et affirmer que la différence existe dans ce monde et qu'il y en aura toujours.
Il faudra vous y habituer.
On peut affirmer ça sans aucun mot.
La mode peut nous donner une langue pour le désaccord.
Elle peut nous donner courage.
La mode nous permet d'afficher notre courage, littéralement.
Alors portez-le.
Portez-le, comme une armure.
Portez-le parce que c'est important.
Et portez-le parce que vous êtes important.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)